over the years videogames have inspired
engineers to come up with outlandish and
unusual controllers some are just crazy
enough to work and others were just well
crazy thankfully the days of gimmicky
controllers and apparatuses are mostly
behind us but there's still a desire to
enhance the way we interface with our
games oculus and the likes are keen to
get us into VR headsets Microsoft
encourages us to shout and wave our
hands at our TVs the rifting Kinect are
well known at this point but there's a
lesser-known innovation just around the
corner that may soon alter not just how
we control characters that have
developers create their games tobe
technology is a leader in AI tracking
having proved itself in non gaming
markets for years but it's finally
stepping into the ring with devices like
SteelSeries i century with infrared
lights and a few cameras its devices and
software can tell exactly where you're
looking and third parties such as
developers like Ubisoft can use that
information to enhance the gameplay
experience it's a common sounding claim
but after toying around with the PC
version of Assassin's Creed rogue with
Ubisoft's custom eye tracking controls
I'm a believer I tracking isn't the next
in a long line of gimmicks it's going to
fundamentally change the way we interact
with games it's not whether it's used by
developers or not but whether it's
implemented in a way that adds to the
experience rather than detracting from
it so I sat down with Assassin's Creed
rogue the promise I could use my gaze to
control the camera and my character's
movement the result it worked perfectly
with my thumb pushing forward on the
left analog stick shady assassin I ran
and with my eye on the prize he steered
himself in the right direction it took a
moment for me to relax and let the
eye-tracking do its thing but when I
shed my deliberate actions for pure
instinct I was amazed by how accurate
the eye tracking was and how I forgot it
was using it at all so eye tracking can
influence how you control your character
in a game but it can also influence how
you interact with a cast of characters
and influence storylines if a game can
tell you're paying attention to one
person on a screen versus another
allegiances and relationships can be
influenced this is something we already
do in games but we make deliberate
decisions in today's model with eye
tracking our natural tendencies can
speak for themselves granted this
technology is currently being pitched
only to early adopters and it will
require more games and easier access to
tracking devices like the century to
grow the market but having experienced
how well the tech works there's no doubt
in my mind that the thousands of dev
kits currently in the wild will lead to
some amazing and unexpected experiences
I tracking gives you more control over
games without demanding more from your
hands and opens the door from mentally
immersive experiences that will lead to
more effective and personalized
storytelling sure
skeptics may call it a gimmick I
certainly thought it would be however
after 10 minutes playing Assassin's
Creed Road with eye tracking I can't get
my hands on a century soon enough
you